[Musique]
elle envoie ce matin là franck et
rodolphe joue sur du velours pour faire
ces quelques mètres il emploie
d'infinies précautions
surtout pas de mouvements brusques en
fraîche puisque ça risquerait d'abîmer
la pigmentation des tableaux et il doit
jamais reposé au sort il doit toujours
reposé sur quelque chose qui nous
protège
il transporte l'un des tableaux de la
collection richelieu pour l'acheminer
dans la salle d'exposition mais avant il
doit passer un examen
un constat d'état réalisé par les deux
jeunes conservatrice du musée
olivia et viviane qui ont pris leurs
fonctions il y à peine deux ans leur
nous vérifions avant de prévoir son
accrochage que le tableau est stable en
bon état qu'il n'y a pas de soulèvement
puisque un tableau peut avoir des
problèmes de support et la couche
picturale se désolidarise du support
c'est une série qui a une histoire
étonnante attachante puisqu'ils
proviennent du château de richelieu qui
a été démantelée en 1800
vendu à la pièce est piloté grenet d'un
marchand orléanais a acheté lors de la
vente
plusieurs tableaux provenant du château
de richelieu donc og le maire de
l'époque et son adjoint le compte de
bizemont ont fait un appel aux dons
demandant aux orléanais de donner leurs
collections pour fonder un grand musée
alors le musée existait déjà mais les
collections d'été assez modeste et à ce
moment là
en 1825 un grand nombre de relais à
néant donné leur collection c'est une
histoire complètement folle il reste
deux pièces à transporter pour cette
matinée au format hors norme et leur
emballage requiert toute l'attention de
l'équipe est en train de
de faire un emballage pour une peinture
de grand format qu'on doit sortir de la
réserve est monté dans les salles
d'exposition
c'est une opération un peu particulière
parce que ce tableau ne rentre pas dans
l'ascenseur donc il va falloir qu'on le
groupe par là
la trémie qui dessert tout les simples
difficile de manipuler un grand format
est donc ce sont des moments de la
détention mais où chacun est très
concentré et surtout le maître mot c'est
qu'il faut prendre soin pas prendre son
temps
technicien régisseuse ou conservatrice
tous ont à coeur de continuer à faire
traverser les siècles à ses oeuvres un
bel éloge de la lenteur
demain nous retrouverons les
travailleurs de l'ombre
olivier rodolphe et franck dans les
entrailles du musée pour un exercice de
passe muraille